[Música]
qué es lo primero que piensan cuando ven
el número en la pantalla será la
cantidad de pasos que di en todo el año
será la cantidad de colones que me voy a
ganar cuando pegue el gordito navideño
la verdad no lo sé pero lo que sí
podemos tener claro es que es un número
bastante grande
/ hundidas inundaciones terremotos
sequías y tormentas se han visto
afectados 152 millones de
latinoamericanos en los últimos 20 años
en este mismo periodo de tiempo se han
registrado 1200 desastres naturales un
dato muy interesante sólo 12 de estos
han causado daños estimados alrededor de
1 billón de dólares
si hacemos una pequeña ecuación
matemática podemos estimar que el
impacto de cada uno de los desastres
naturales ronda en los 100 millones de
dólares cada uno como ven son números
bastantes grandes los que estamos
hablando es por eso que las entidades
gubernamentales están trabajando en
conjunto para crear planes de acción
para poder mitigar los efectos de este
los objetivos de desarrollo de
sostenibilidad creados por las naciones
unidas en el 2015 es un claro ejemplo de
este de este trabajo en conjunto estos
tienen como meta el garantizar no es un
mundo sostenible para el 2030
está compuesto por 17 objetivos que
contienen metas específicas que tenemos
que lograr en los próximos nueve años
quiero ejemplificar un poquito cómo se
mide cada objetivo entonces voy a tocar
tres el primero que habla sobre el fin
de la pobreza podemos encontrar métricas
que habla sobre cómo podemos reducir la
pobreza extrema en el mundo o si nos
vamos a otro objetivo como el número 7
que habla sobre la energía podemos saber
métricas de cómo como todas las personas
pueden acceder a la electricidad
universal o como por último nos vamos al
objetivo desarrollo sostenible en número
8 que habla sobre el trabajo decente y
el crecimiento económico y aquí podemos
encontrar métricas que habla sobre cómo
podemos agregar un segmento de población
y podemos subir el pib per cápita a ese
segmento específico
lastimosamente seis años después de
firmados estos compromisos y con el
compromiso de 193 naciones los
resultados a hoy no son alentadores
según el secretario nacional de las
naciones unidas- antonio guterres estima
que en los próximos dos a tres años 71
millones de personas van a volver al
índice de pobreza extrema
entonces yo me hago la pregunta por qué
estamos fallando si hay compromiso si
hay voluntad qué es lo que está pasando
entonces me hago la pregunta qué pasa si
incluimos al sector privado en la
ecuación qué pasa si ayudamos al sector
privado a entender el concepto la
sostenibilidad a estandarizar sus
métricas de impacto y por último a
gestionar mejor gestionar
sosteniblemente sus recursos
primero hay que entender el concepto de
la sostenibilidad
existen muchísimos tabús sobre esto y
quiero hablarles uno que me da muchísima
risa porque es lo que más escucho cuando
hablamos de sostenibilidad lo único que
pensamos es en las cosas verdes ya qué
me refiero con las cosas verdes me
refiero a que voy a plantar un arbolito
con el vecino me refiero me refiero
también a que tengo una compostera en mi
casa o simplemente que recojo bien la
basura cuando la sostenibilidad es es un
es un círculo muy amplio y tiene tres
ámbitos que es el social el económico y
lo ambiental
utilizando los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible como base medición creamos
una herramienta en un mismo ecosistema
que puede y como la girl como la guisa
todas las métricas en un mismo
ecosistema ayudamos a las empresas
privadas a que tienen aquellas tienen
tanta información se lo consolidamos en
un solo lugar para que sea más fácil
gestionar y tener métricas de impactos
a todos los empresarios que nos están
viendo el día de hoy les tengo una
noticia
sus empresas ya tienen elementos que
pueden ser ligados a la sostenibilidad y
les quiero ejemplificar un poquito si su
empresa ya tiene una planilla
establecida ustedes pueden ya ligar sus
métricas al objetivo desarrollo
sostenible número 8 con empleabilidad
si sus empresas tienen políticas de
equidad de género ya podemos ligar
métricas al objetivo desarrollo
sostenible número 5 que habla sobre la
equidad de género
creo fielmente que lo que no se mide no
se puede mejorar y es por eso que el
tener métricas cuantitativas nos da un
mejor panorama para tomar mejores
decisiones
es importante ver es importante ver que
la información usándola correctamente va
a determinar nuestro comportamiento
hiciera volver al número inicial de los
152 millones de latinoamericanos
afectados
pues costa rica- no es la excepción ya
estamos viviendo los primeros estragos
del cambio climático con escasez de agua
en la zona norte con cortes de
electricidad y también con la aparición
de nuevas enfermedades
pero nosotros como costarricenses
tenemos una ventaja vivimos en un país
altamente
comprometido con el medio ambiente con
la sostenibilidad
hace menos de un mes nos otorgaron un
premio internacional el príncipe que el
príncipe guillermo donde se ratifica el
compromiso que costa rica tiene en estos
temas
para terminar
hoy como padre de familia yo veo el
mundo que le quiero dar a mi hijo y me
recuerdo lo equivocados que estábamos en
mis épocas de la escuela me recuerdo que
inclusive me enseñaban que el agua era
un recurso inagotable que tan
equivocados estábamos
ahora como padre de familia quiero poder
ver a mi hijo cuando sea grande y poder
decirle a los ojos tu papá contribuyó
para que tú tuvieras un mundo mejor
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]